so I'm going to talk about the inversion
of masculine and feminine symbolism in
popular culture just looking at the
title
it seems very polemical and in a way I
guess there's a part of it that is it
but I hope that we can work through very
quickly the polemical aspect of it and
come to show the beauty of the symbolism
of the feminine that we have in the
Orthodox tradition and so if you bear
with me we will get through the the
difficult part at the beginning so
what's happening today
in popular culture is that there has
been for several years for decades even
there has been this call to have more
what people are calling gender equality
in popular culture and so this call to
have more female protagonists in movies
and TV shows in you know even in video
games and comic books all all of the
popular cultures there's been this call
to have these strong female protagonists
and so what has slowly kind of come out
of that is exactly that we have this
string of manifestations movies comics
video games all of this that have the
the when I guess we could call the the
badass you know feminine character who
who she's strong she fights she she she
she beats up everybody and so in a
certain manner the hope the trope is
that she this character which has all
kinds of manifestations is there too in
a way
manifests the same idea of the action
hero or the superhero or the military
hero but as a woman and so we see that
we recognize them we saw just
I think these these are from just this
year from just this year Marvel Comics
Star Wars all these these these feminine
characters who are who are strong we're
fighting and who beat up all the guys
around them now the thing I want to
point attention to is that as we watch
this as we watch this characterization
there's something that's happening also
at the same time what we're seeing is
not only the representation of these
feminine heroes but at the same time we
see a strange demeaning or strange
mocking a strange humiliating of the
masculine characters within those same
stories and so at first you would think
that this is a question of a parody
right we we have these these masculine
heroes would be good to also have
feminine heroes that we can look up to
in the same way that we look up to these
masculine tears but what's strange is
that in the stories this many of the
stories have this other trope which is
to step on or to to mock so for example
that there's a they did a version of
Ghostbusters everybody that's probably
seen this they did a version of
Ghostbusters recently that had it all
feminine cast and in the story which was
in a way not necessary that they did so
there's a scene where the old
Ghostbuster who was a man Bill Murray
she's sitting there in a room and they
blow him out of the building and he dies
lands on the head of the hood of a car
and he dies there and you see the ladies
come up to the window I said I guess he
wasn't Ghostbuster material right and
you think I mean it's a joke and it's
it's fine it's a joke the problem is not
that one joke the the the difficulty
which appears is when it becomes a
pattern right and that's what that's
what I'm sensitive to is to to be
attentive to the pattern
[Music]
there's a there's a recent there's a
recent video game that came out and it
is it's creating a lot of controversy
because the video game is supposed to be
a historical very historically accurate
representation of world war ii and the
fighting in world war ii and in the
video game it's it's like 50/50 you know
they have women people fight it's women
fighting in the world war ii then they
put a woman on the cover she's got a
mechanical arm and cheechee no she's
fighting in world war ii and so people
are wondering like what this is
obviously not a historical
representation of world war ii you know
not that there were women involved in
the war effort of course there were but
you know 95% of the native 99% of the
people who actually held a weapon in
world war ii would have been men and so
what is like what is the what is the
impetus behind that and what i am trying
to what i want to suggest to you is
there really is this strange inversion
which is setting up where we do want to
have this feminine character but we want
the feminine character to embody all
that is masculine we are looking and so
it's basically if you look at the
superhero characters it it's the same
superhero character that was Superman
Batman all those those those masculine
characters it's only that it's act it's
a it's physically a woman um now the one
of the one of the examples of that
everybody has seen the the Star Wars the
latest Star Wars movie so if you look at
the cover of the magazine right you you
get a sense that the cover of the
magazine itself it's telling you what it
is that they're hoping to accomplish and
so you have up there it says right can
poke it along with his new boss and in
the movie you have the scene where this
care
just appear that the movie is
humiliating the female character and the
trope repeats itself in the movie
several times you see these characters
being humiliated given a lesson taught
something and like I said it's not the
act itself because in a story you can
have all kinds of things happen and it's
okay to have variations that they have
this the the problem the the question
that is brought up is when we start to
see it as this constant pattern which
appears over and over in stories that's
when we start to wonder what exactly is
is happening is happening in these
stories because of course there are
always exceptions right there is such a
thing as a extremely strong woman that
could probably beat up anybody in this
room that does exist the question is not
whether or not there are exceptions the
question is what is the pattern right
what is the what is the social pattern
that is trying to be shown to us so in
in the in the latest movie The
Incredibles - you really see this
inversion played out completely they
have the female character we are told
that the male character is too reckless
he's too chaotic he he can't control
himself you know he breaks everything
and so we're we're told that it's her
she has to be the hero now and he has to
stay home and take care of the children
and what's fascinating and this is going
to be important as we as we move forward
in the story is that in the the story
itself the the lady is amazing she's an
amazing super it's actually it's
actually I actually enjoyed watching the
movie because it was so well done so
well put together so the woman is
amazing - doing all these amazing things
visually impressive and everything and
then the maximum character sorry I did I
forgot to change this line and the
masculine character is taking care of
the kids but he can't but he's
completely useless he's
you know everything is crumbling around
him and he doesn't sleep and he's become
a total rep until you have you really
have this dichotomy where you have one
character which is shining which is
amazing and then the other character the
father who is basically you know can't
do it just can't can't hold it together
and we've seen I mean we've seen this
this character we've seen this character
in television and in movies now for the
last few decades it's it's Homer Simpson
it's the family guy it's all those idiot
father's right
you know they've been they've given them
to us you know piece by piece you know
and it so when we see this now it's
almost as if we're used to seeing this
trope in this in storage we've seen it
now for so many decades that when we see
the idiot father who can't do anything
right and is it's kind of breaking
everything and and can't get his act
together we think that that's the normal
it's a pattern of a story now a lot of
people will think that obviously I am
exaggerating a lot of people think that
I am seeing this from a certain angle
maybe from a traditional angle however
it is but you have to pay attention to
what's going on because what you find is
as these stories come out the the people
who are promoting the stories in the
media in the you know in the even in
journalism they're celebrating what I'm
what I'm showing right they're actually
celebrating that this has happened so
it's not just that it's happening is
that it's being celebrated and so for
example in this in a recent in the
recent movie called ant-man and the wasp
you have this very pattern happening so
they made the first movie it was a it
was a male character and then the second
movie you have a
character which use herbs his place in
the story and not only that but the male
character becomes this kind of idiotic
you know everything that he does is kind
of he he succeeds only by chance he has
no skill he's kind of the goofy idiot
and in the in the press I'll read you a
this is from this article that I put up
here the the author of the article she
lays it out herself she said we asked
for more powerful women so here we are
so the wasp is the best hero her mom is
smarter than everyone the villain is a
girl too the dudes in this movie are
hapless and only succeed by accident and
every one of those sentences has an
exclamation point and she is celebrating
she is celebrating the fact that that
the masculine hero is being demean and
is being kind of set aside for for for
this kind of ascent of this feminine
superhero and so I think that this is
this is really the ultimate version so
in Marvel Comics they they created this
character who is Captain Marvel which is
quite recent in Marvel Comics and
they're making her out to be the most so
she is the most powerful character in
the entire universe and week if you look
again at the magazine cover you can see
that this is not they're not this is
purposeful can you see up there it says
the future is female so there's there's
this celebration and the celebration is
not of a kind of equality of a kind of
parody which is what we were told that
what it was supposed to be it was
supposed to be a world where men and
women are equal where men and women work
together where you know we don't
differentiate the genders so much but
that's not what's happening we're seeing
is rather a revolutionary trope where
one is trying to supplant the other so
why does it happen that way
why does it have to become upside down
and the problem is this is that we
believed we were told that equality
means saying that if we're to believe in
equality of the sexes we somehow have to
believe that they are the same that
there's no difference between the two
and that is not true right
I mean the entire tradition of human
existence has shown us that all
societies at a time from the beginning
have in different ways but have always
demarcated the masculine and feminine
and have had gender roles in society
there they have been different I'm not
saying that in all societies have had
the same role but they have always had
that distinction and it's been you know
that the difference was acknowledged and
actually the difference was was
celebrated and so in order to you would
say overcompensate so in order to say we
can have women who are as badass as you
know tough as much a fighter as much a
killer as a as a man the only way to do
it is is to flip it because you have to
overcompensate for the for the illusion
because we know that that's not the case
or at least has not been the case in the
entire history of humanity so there's
this desire to overcompensate and that
overcompensation
creates this inversion
which not only the ascent which is
needed but it's also the demeaning which
is needed to so the pattern of masculine
and feminine is one of the most
permanent patterns in all traditions you
know in all cultures it takes different
forms of course everybody will know this
symbol so the yin-yang symbol is a
symbol of heaven and earth it's also a
symbol of masculine feminine a symbol of
that duality but a duality of course
which is together right it's not not an
open opposition completely you know you
could see it as a complementary
complementary relationship and in in so
many traditions you have that played
over you have it in Greek mythology of
Gaia and Uranus you have in Mesopotamian
you mrs. mr. Damian mythology have
Tiamat and absolute these kind of
primordial either it's heaven and earth
or sometimes it can be freshwater or
saltwater but this relationship of two
complementary you know opposites that
come together to then produce something
to produce the world and in the Bible we
have a similar pattern we have this set
up at the beginning of Genesis we have
heaven and earth this kind of primordial
duality and this this kind of primordial
duality in the creation story itself you
see how it's coming closer to each other
you see these different separations but
we're coming closer we have you know the
heavens and then we have the water than
the separation of the waters the earth
comes out of the waters we have fish and
and birds
if you always wondered why we have birds
and fish created on the same day because
it's to repeat that same pattern heaven
and our
below and above so it keeps repeating
and then it comes down to the human
being and then God takes the dust of the
earth and then blows in the air into his
lungs the spirit when we read spirit I
always have to remember that spirit wind
is it's the same word so you have this
union of heaven and earth which appears
in man and it said that man was created
male and female and then we have Adam
and Eve as the result of that repetition
of the basic pattern which was there
right from the beginning and so there's
something there's something that is
extremely primordial about that
relationship and if we if we completely
set it aside we are going to miss a very
important aspect of who we are as human
being in in the gospel there is a call
there is a call for us to transcend the
opposites right we see it in st. Paul's
they call tells us right there is
neither male nor female neither Greek
nor Jew right neither slave nor free and
there is this call to transcend the
opposites but there's a very big
difference between transcending
something and confusing something and
hopefully if you look at what I've been
telling you about to have this let's say
ascendance of feminine character which
wants to take all the masculine
qualities while at the same time
demeaning the masculine characters of
the story what you have is not you don't
have this transcendence you have
confusion and an inversion and you have
a conflict right you have you have this
perpetuation of a fight and there's now
it's just one side that's losing there
are were times in his room maybe was the
other side
I was losing and now we have this other
this other situation and we can see we
can see in the the imagery that Saint
Paul uses about of marriage we can find
a glimpse of what it looks like to
transcend the opposite because in the
union of male and female in the union of
masculine and feminine st. Paul tells us
we are one body there's an actual unity
which is created in that bond of
marriage and that unity which in a
certain manner transcends the duality
because it unifies them together it is
it's productive it produces children
produce this community produces family
and so when that happens there is a a
productive result whereas when we have
the the this inversion the result of
that is the opposite it's it's conflict
and it's also sterility
and once we understand the basic
elements of let's say that basic
opposite of masculine feminine once we
understand that it does in fact set
itself up in society as male and female
we can then also see that it is of
course more than that then in a certain
manner we are we are called to play
those roles in our lives as well as the
church we as some people like I am
called to be the Bride of Christ I am
called to to to also participate in the
the the powerful and beautiful symbolism
of the feminine and then encounter my
Lord in that manner so it's not just
it's not just about like I said it's not
just about polemics and about
complaining about some political change
that is happening in front of our eyes
there's something much deeper there it's
something much deeper which needs to to
be understood now the problem the trick
in this this is really the the thing
that I think is is in a way unexpected
by many people is that when we look at
the trope okay so when we look at the at
the trope of this of the badass feminine
character what seems to be happening is
that in fact what we're praising what
we're celebrating is actually not the
feminine what we're praising what we're
celebrating is the very you know the
very classical masculine traits of being
strong of you know of being tough of
being able to fight all those types of
kind of traditional male tropes that is
what we end up celebrating and so the
inversion actually creates this strange
contradiction which what is being
diminished in the end or what is being
let put to the side is the
beautiful and the powerful feminine
symbolism which has been held by
humanity for thousands of years we are
ignoring it we are pretending as if what
really matters what's really important
is that we can embody those roles that
what matters is to be the CEO we all we
want to know is how many female CEOs
there are how many you know female
policemen there are how many that's what
we want to know but we're not we've
forgotten we've we've abandoned a
celebration of the beautiful imagery of
of the feminine so this I want to show
you an icon this icon in the in the in
the Orthodox tradition could be the most
let's say celebratory of what we'd call
kind of the hero type of behavior right
it's it's very very it encapsulates
pretty much simply everything that's
going on we have a princess who is in
distress and there is someone who comes
and kills the dragon in order to save
the princess and so it has its place I
can it definitely has its place now the
thing is that there is another version
of this story there's another it's not
the same story but there is a feminine
version of this interaction between the
masculine and the feminine so this isn't
this is a version and I think it has it
has some importance but there is also a
masculine version right and so in for
example the story of Beauty and the
Beast we have a masculine character who
is monster right who is out of control
who is who wants to control everything
who wants to hold her if he wants to
capture her wants to control her her her
presence there and in the story what
happens is that beauty is able to tame
the male monster and she's able to
transform him into a man now this story
is it's not just Beauty and the Beast
there are many examples of this one of
the one of my favorite examples of this
this story is is a it's called Howl's
Moving Castle it's by Japanese director
and a Miyazaki and in this story we have
that very trope and the character the
feminine character is extremely powerful
she basically holds the life of this
monstrous masculine character in her
hands and she slowly brings him to to to
uh to transform and to open up a new
space in which he can be more than what
he was before but think of think over
not just in popular culture and the
Bible we have the story of Queen Esther
and the story of Queen Esther is pretty
much the same story as Beauty and the
Beast we have this foreign King who
everything is they're set up to destroy
the Jews and then her through her grace
through her manner in which she is able
to approach the king contain him you
would say she raised the king she
invites the king to her house and the
King enters into her house and then she
reveals to him this secret that in fact
Haman wanted to kill the Jews and in
revealing this beautiful secret despite
this powerful secret then the king
changes and things flip over and then
the King turns against
and I mean there are many many other
stories there's a in the very very
ancient stories in the story of
Gilgamesh we have a very similar story
we have a beast named Enkidu who is
basically a wild creature in the the
forest and and this the the people of
the city they send this woman and then
in encounter by encountering this woman
and entering into a relationship with
this woman he then learns to become a
human being so it's a very very ancient
story and it's a very powerful story
which shows you the other side instead
of just wanting to put a woman on the
horse st. George's horse who kills the
dragon it shows another aspect another
very powerful aspect of what the flip
side of that story is so let's look at
this this image again now
we have many images of what feminine
symbolism in in the church in our
tradition and many of them they turn
around the mother of God and the images
that we use for the mother of God our
images of her being the the opening up
of this place the opening up of this
possibility she is the temple she is the
Ark of the Covenant
she is the dawn there are all these
images that we use of her to to to show
her as this this place in which
something will happen in which the
divine will manifest itself and so even
even in so the mother of God becomes the
frame she becomes the the frame into
which the manifestation happens and we
can see that even in this icon here
right we can see that even though we
have this idea of the helpless princess
for example that the princess is the one
who is enticing if you will the hero to
act without without her there's nothing
happens
there is no heroic action and that can
be good or bad this is just a structure
it can be good or bad if you look at the
Trojan War right we have the same
structure the trojan war is fought over
Helen of Troy
she is the she is the one who brings the
Greek state that's why the Greeks are
called Helens right she is the one who
actually entices the Greeks to join
together in order to fight and rescue
her from the Trojans and so she becomes
that the the space into which these
Greeks can come and be come
they actually manifest something so am i
dead right and so we have this image we
have this image of the mother of god of
Mary as this frame as the space as the
opening up of the possibility so you can
see her in this this is the most ancient
tradition of the representation the
mother goddess to show rather the throne
of wisdom to show her as this throne but
if you look at the image you'll see that
she is also this frame
she is the space out of which you know
the the Sun rises the space out of which
something is happening and that that
pattern is going to be the pattern of
this this mysterious presence of the
feminine always there in the church
always there and following the story of
the church and I'm gonna show you this
pattern so this is the winning the
wedding of Cana now in the story we see
exactly it's one of the it's one of my
favorite stories in the gospel because
Christ is hidden Christ is not acting
no one knows she's a secret she knows
the secret
she's the only she's the only one she
knows the secret but Christ is not
acting and so then there is a problem no
why so she goes up to Christ and she
says there's a problem there's no one
and it's it's very fascinating because
what does Christ answer he says my time
has not yet come you think that is a
crazy answer
she's telling him there's not enough
wine and he's answering I'm not willing
to die it
how do those things relate and they
relate in the fact that she is inviting
him she's inviting her son she is saying
here's the question
show me the word show me the answer give
give us the answer she is there's that
crazy it scene in the movie My Big Fat
Greek Wedding I I love that scene when
everybody knows it when the the lady she
says you know the man is the head of the
household but the woman is the neck and
we think it's funny and it's hilarious
but I think there's something very
profound in that statement because the
mother God is saying this is the place
where I'm asking you to manifest
yourself and then Christ has to decide
whether or not he's going to do it now
think of that think of that in our lives
think of that as a church what do we do
what does the church do we ask we pray
we ask God we say here is my suffering
here is my sin here is my question and
we ask God to manifest himself in that
space that we open up as the church and
what does the church say in the book of
Revelation at the end what do they do
they think they're calling their
enticing they're asking they're saying
come Lord Jesus they're asking for
Christ to return and that is really the
that is really the powerful symbolism of
the feminine as it manifests itself in
the in the church now this structure I
think it's the it's kind of the opening
scene for this where we really see the
mother of God inviting Christ to
manifest himself him knowing that if he
shows himself to the world it's going to
lead him on this path to his death he
knows
ready that's where he's going but this
is the opening of that new space for him
to enter into okay
if you're interested I wrote an article
called sacred art and the power of women
you can find that Google they find it
and one of the things I'm sure I show is
that Eve did that too like she she she
enticed like she kind of opened up a
space for Adam and that that space was
was was a fall and then the mother of
God does the same but she flips it right
she opens up the space again and then
she flips it so that now it's it's to
our salvation it's very powerful I think
it's just those beautiful patterns in
there and the big story now the pattern
repeats itself over and over we have for
example in the the judgment of Christ
there is pilot who's there and has to
judge Christ but in the background of
that story
there is pilots wife we actually
venerate as saint pro kleh and she
secretly no one in the no one in the
crowd knew but she's secretly in
whispering in his ear she said this man
you know he's special
be careful don't don't mess with you
then we have the same structure who is
the first person to go to the empty
grave who is the first person who alone
in that secret encounter to encounter
the risen Lord its Mary Magdalene and
then she goes to the disciples and then
the disciples will encounter him in the
in the space and they will also be the
ones who will and the proclaiming the
resurrection of Christ but she is the
one who opened up that space
then we have all the royal women of our
history every single or art royal women
every time a nation may not every time
maybe it is but at least that we know it
there are so many example that when a
nation converts to Christianity
what's the trope the trope is the same
there is a woman who converts and it's
there's this private secret encounter
that we don't even know we don't know
what those women told to their sons or
to their grandsons are to their husbands
but we see the pattern right we have we
have we have sankt we have st. Helen who
converts and then Constantine we have
Saint Olga the grandmother of st.
Vladimir who converts and then st.
Vladimir but it's everywhere
the first Frankish king Clovis the first
Christian Frankish king who converted
first his wife the first British King
King Ethelbert is that a pronouncing
King Ethelbert of Kent it was his wife
who converted first his pattern is
non-stop and we see it not only with the
the the the royalty but we see it with
the Saints too we see st. Monica who
converts and then we have Augustine who
is the Western pillar you know the
Western he is basic you know he's that
on which the west is founded and then we
also have we also have st. Macrina the
sister of st. basil of the Cappadocia
ins who converts and then her family
converts and so this the difficulty
about this is that you know we often say
in the Orthodox Church that that the
mother of God is a mystery of the church
we always say that we say we don't have
too many doctrines about her but we have
is that encounter that secret encounter
as you enter into the life of the church
you discover the mother of God and so
you know I I even always have hidden
hesitating to even talk about this
subject because in a way here I am
proclaiming something that is supposed
to be right this this thing that you
discover as you look and it's not there
it's you know this pattern no one will
say oh look you know the mother of
Constantine can written before and so
hey we that's not that it's it's
something which is hidden and it's this
secret opening of a space and so in a
certain manner it's something that we
probably shouldn't be talking about but
that we should we should probably be
experiencing and discovering in that
secret place but I think that the reason
why I want to talk about it is that I as
I believe that it's that this this this
beautiful symbolism of the feminine is
something we have as this precious jewel
and in a world where we're so confused
about these questions we're we're so we
think somehow that value is to be strong
is to be a fighter is to be to be on top
is to be leader and then we forget the
value of the private space of caring the
value of of caring for those that are
there of also discovering that
mysterious opening of the place where
God can enter into our own lives there's
this image if this everybody knows about
the song of songs in the Old Testament
where it is this song Song of Solomon
where it is that basically a a romantic
discussion between a lover and and of
two lovers and the church fathers have
always interpreted that as this
relationship that we are meant to have
with God that as we need to be able to
in have
that feminine space of opening up the
possibility of then encountering this
life this light that we saw in the Honda
on the the knees of the mother of God
the light that we see when we look in
the apse of our churches and we see the
pan aghia with their arms open in Christ
who is coming out of the dawn who is who
is showing himself on the ark who is
sitting on his throne and so I think
that we we need to be aware of that and
be able to explore and to celebrate that
beauty and not let ourselves fall into
the War of the sexes that we see raging
around us
and so thank you very much that's what I
had for you tonight so I if you have
questions then I will open up the space
for you I'm ready for the arrows but you
know
ok I'll hide behind the Thea
yeah I know
no I don't think it's tongue-in-cheek I
think that you know I think you know
there's a there's a there's a saying of
Christ which I love Christ says scandal
must happen right but but won't by those
by who it happens I always I have this
sense that if when I think of the French
Revolution or I think of the Russian
Revolution I think that the groans of
the people were justified and real I
don't agree with a revolution but I
think that the the king who does not
listen to the groaning of his people
that it's going to happen right and so I
do think that we have seen even in the
19th like since the Enlightenment I
would say since the Enlightenment kind
of accelerated we have seen a masculine
tyranny I would say of the space whereas
in the Middle Ages where the in the
traditional world there was this this
this real celebration of the mother of
God I mean even though the warriors
right in the West for example all the
Templars and all the Knights went on
crusade they were completely devoted to
their lady and and it was this there was
this this powerful relationship of
relationships between the masculine and
feminine and I think that we have kind
of seen with the Enlightenment and you
know the that say the primacy of reason
over everything all of that has led to
this extremely masculine space in which
it seemed like the only thing to be was
that and so all right so I I have
sympathy for for you know women who say
well I want to have you know where is
the value where is the value of
women and they want to take that value
from the masculine image and we have not
we don't celebrate it we do we celebrate
motherhood do we celebrate caring do we
celebrate the the kind of the secret of
the private space we're eliminating the
private space it's almost gone and so I
think that I think you're in a way
you're right with that I don't think I
think that in our reaction to that
shouldn't be to like to to enter the
revolution but rather to to rediscover
the beauty and the power of live of this
feminine symbolism rather than play
along with this this game is being
played because it will make us miserable
because we need each other so if we play
this war who's going to win nobody's
gonna win well I think I think that I
think that in a way yes I mean obviously
we need to not make much attention to
entertainment but we are our world is
led by entertainment we are it's all
bread and circuses for us pretty much
and so that we that's where the patterns
are going to appear and so like I said I
think that what we see is a pattern and
that's what we need to to see and not
only the patter but like I said it's not
just the pattern but it's the
celebration of the pattern which both
together make us see that this is not
this is not just something that is
accidental that there really is this
this desire to to create this change but
yeah I don't think it's going to I think
it at some point it's going to collapse
the thing I'm afraid of actually if it
collapses is
is I'm afraid of them I'm afraid of the
backlash in a way more than I'm afraid
of of this
I'm afraid that at some point some very
angry people are going to start to be
more aggressive about this question
right you know like that the backlash
against this is what I'm actually more
afraid of so I love my I think that my
my approach to this question has always
been to try to say to the yes point to
the problem with mostly tried to point
to the beauty that we have in that we
can we can show people hopefully that's
what I'm doing I don't know I think they
come I think they come from Genesis I
think they come from that first set up
of heaven and earth and so we have this
have this imagery that we use which is
our Father in Heaven and so we have this
notion this association let's say with
heaven or that's a spiritual world as
being name identity qualities of things
right and then if you see how the story
plays itself out in Genesis there is
this God said Let there be it's very
beautiful right so he calls the earth to
produce the different animals the
different plants and everything and so
it's like there is a name there is a a
naming and then there is this work of
bringing together and kind of producing
the the creation which comes out of the
earth and I think that that is our basic
understanding of what masculine
and then we we also then that that is
then understood in the you know that the
manner in which the ancients understood
the sexual union of masculine and
feminine as being a as representing that
same pattern as playing that pattern
over again and so and you can see it you
know we always have to we have to kind
of interpret the world
phenomenologically not when we try to
interpret it scientifically this this
gets weird but when we interpret it
phenomenologically we can understand it
know uh someone sees a the seed which
falls from a trees there's nothing right
it's nothing it's the mustard seed
there's it's nothing then it falls into
the earth and then it grows and so the
seed is giving that point right the
Pearl in the field that that that name
and then the field and then the
production of this life that becomes the
say the feminine the feminine answer to
this this relationship and so then we
continue on and we continue to see how
st. Paul talks about the the
relationship between Christ and the
church and how he also relates that
relationship to the relationship between
a husband and a wife so you can see the
same the same patterns being played out
and so the church you know if you look
at the if you look at the if you look at
the architecture of a church you can you
can see this I mean it's it's right
there we have in the in the apse as a
pen Agia who is the dawn right it was
this space out of which the Sun is
rising in the east and then at the top
of the dome we have the fully manifest
glorious Christ who is there in the dome
then we go to the west and we have the
falling asleep of the mother of God and
we have this final coming together of
the story where then she just like he
was just like the yin-yang symbol it I
always tell people the the apps and the
western wall is like a yin-yang symbol
you have Christ in the mother of God's
arms in the apse then you have the
mother of God in Christ arms in the West
and there's this beautiful completeness
of that relationship so I think I mean I
could go on forever but but I think that
it's it's out of the Bible out of
Genesis st. Paul and then you know that
I mean obviously as an iconographer I
get a lot of my cues from from
iconography and so you know if you look
at the image of the Ascension it's it's
a very powerful image of that basic
relationship so you have Christ up in
heaven with the Angels in this mandorla
and then you have the mother of God who
is under him
praying as this space right this space
which is that of which Christ is the
head but who is also waiting to to once
again be united with her with her son
and then out of her you know on the
sides you have then the Apostles and the
church kind of kind of manifesting
themselves out you know on the sides of
her as being this this this basic space
and and some of the icons do the
Ascension you you see even it's very
powerful because you'll see the mother
God is standing on a little square foot
rest right until Christ is sitting on a
rainbow she's sitting on the heavens and
then she is standing on this footrest
and it refers to the Psalms where it
says you know the heavens are the throne
of God and the earth is his footstool
and so this this with this relationship
between the earth the feminine this
footstool the church all of this kind of
comes together that's kind of money yeah
follow so when these symbols are
expressed in men and women is that an
expression of nature of virtue or
something else what do you I do I'm not
sure I understand the masculine
expression of virtues I think it talked
about I think it's an aspect of the
cosmos but I think it's there right
there and then the separation of having
an earth right there and the cosmic
structure it's right I just see it as
the basic pattern of reality manifesting
itself at different levels and then it
also manifests itself in male and female
and so like I said I do think that
Christ calls us to transcend that
opposite but at the same time the
transcending of those opposites is it is
a it's the image that we have of it is
the marriage and it is this this
productive Union and it's not a kind of
everybody can be whatever they think
which is what we kind of get in our
culture today which is that everybody
can have can just kind of play out
whatever characteristics that fits their
fancy not that not that these things are
these are patterns right they're not
they're not absolute in in in every
individual manifestation of something I
mean like I said we are called to play I
think that everybody and sometimes is
called to play masculine roles and
sometimes we're called to play feminine
roles and sometimes don't ask yourself
that question like it's not it's not
part of the part of what's happening
have the females cast with male roles to
kind of supplant a traditional male
aspects courage bravery strength those
kind of things not only as a way to make
women more powerful but also a way to
make men less powerful do you think
that's not just you know maybe that's
step two but I'm thinking maybe step
three is just a complete decoupling of
any type of gendered virtue any type of
traits you know so that we could just
we're not we don't supplant male with
female we destroy both male and female
I'm wondering if that's where our
cultural ending I think that there's
some people who want that it's clear and
they say it out loud they're not hiding
it I think there's some people who want
that but I don't think it I don't think
it is going to happen and I don't think
Canada right and we can look at we can
look at revolutionary movements to see
like if you look at Marxist Marxist
theory right there is this revolution
the the proletariat take the role they
they take over there's a tyranny of the
proletariat and then after the tune of
the proletariat everything disappears in
every year and having on earth I think
there's some people who think that
that's how it's going to play out but
the problem that it doesn't play itself
out that way you didn't play itself out
that way in Marxism and and it's not
gonna play itself out again in that way
in this structure as well whatever
because they do up that the the only
thing that you can do I think is create
an inversion there's no other way
because in the end if you try to like I
said if you want to suggest that that
that let's say women can be as much as
much a warrior as as as men then you're
going to run into a problem which is
that right which is that reality is
going to resist that proposition so the
only thing you can do is overcompensate
and then that's going to create that
that inversion then there's no way -
there's no way - just there's no way to
destroy it
there it's like you can see it even yeah
try to talk about that but you can't
let's eat let's look at let's look at
let's look at we have this we have the
transgender phenomenon now that's very
strong and in the transgender phenomenon
you have this idea let's say but what
we're seeing is actually not that what
we're seeing are that say people who are
born born masculine who are celebrated
for taking every single cliche trope of
feminine representation and so we could
criticize a woman for wearing high heels
and and red you know and lipstick and
looking like that but if a man does it
then we celebrate it so so it's like it
you can't avoid it's going to come back
so it's going to come back in a strange
mixed-up way but it's going to come back
no matter what
and then the trope the feminine tropes
are appear in the the transgender
movement as well you can't you can't get
away from it I don't think so
and it seems like even moving beyond you
know masculinity and femininity we have
the same cultural war when we try to
think about the modern concept of
Nations like you're talking about we
can't really supplant it we'd only
really transcend it you know it makes me
think about how we a lot of people don't
want their borders these days and you
know when when you get to the biblical
essences of that that's correct which
neither Jew nor Greek but now we get to
the point where it feels like there's no
sense of nation whatsoever there's no
sense you know we're all just human
beings the same way that we're not male
or a female were risking the beams it
feels like we're kind of doing that
among all the different patterns
throughout humanity and it just feels
like you know it's a war of against
humanity itself we're trying to erase
all distinctiveness you know to bring
back to the incredibles if everyone
I mean I think III was I think that I
think that the proper vision of
hierarchy the ISM is always the right
way to see this is that we are one all
one in Christ and and we are called to
be that and but to the extent that we do
have families to the extent that we do
have groups that we associate with if we
can do that in a manner which doesn't
compete with our one unity and our
allegiance to Christ to me that's that's
the goal the problem is when you make a
nation more important than God when you
make your gender more important God when
you make any identity that we can have
when you when you make put that in
competition with the the absolute then
we have idolatry but it doesn't mean
that those act that those different
identities can't exist right and I think
that that's that that's the confusion
we're dealing with now
is that people want to abolish
difference as if that's possible it's
not it's not gonna happen it's gonna
come back sadly it's a key something I
can come back with a the Fuhrer and we
don't want that like the proper
hierarchy of knowing I mean I think that
the Orthodox structure of church it -
it's when it plays itself right when it
when it when it plays it when it's it
can have very negative aspects as we
were seeing recently but when it plays
to its strengths and it acknowledges the
possibility of a diversity of of
churches and diversity of identities all
in communion together so I think that
that's that's the ideal
no I don't think so
well no I think there hope there's a lot
of there are different revolutions kind
of going on this the inversions are
played out in different aspects of
reality I think this one is one that we
can kind of see very clearly we can see
it playing out and so we can can point
to it and say now we have a I think we
have a better answer to offer the world
besides this this kind of this
revolutionary pattern yeah I think it's
part of it I think there's biology as
part of it but I don't think it
encompasses the whole thing at least not
in a biblical perspective I think that
because we have this we have the we have
images of this relationship playing
itself out in our understanding of the
church and Christ in our understanding
of heaven and earth you can see that we
can't limit this to to biology but I
think we're not materialist you know
what biology does play a part in it
obviously there is a biological
difference between between men and women
and I think that to me the day the air
that feminists not all feminists but
let's say the kind of feminists that
would be pushing these types of agendas
the air they're making is is thinking
that what has value is only found in the
masculine trope and then wanting to take
that instead of exploring the exploring
the the other aspect of the world which
is beautiful and which is which is
necessary for the world to exist so I
think that that's the problem sorry
yes yes yeah I think I think I think
you're right I think like like you were
asking before I think that one of the
reasons why this happened is because we
because that we developed a culture that
did not celebrate we didn't like we
celebrate the mother of God we celebrate
her constantly and this we live in a
culture that stopped to do that a long
time ago and I think it's not just that
but there's part of that which is
playing itself out in I would say I
think that in Protestant ontology I
would say we they they don't know where
to put this question they don't know how
to deal with it and so because of it
comes up in all kinds of weird ways
because they they don't have a beautiful
image to point to an icon to point to it
to say look you know and we celebrate
her and who sing we so I think that
that's I think that that's that I think
that's the root of the problem baby
there you go yeah we're glad feels
please
no I think we need to see comfortably we
definitely need to see contraception as
part of a bigger pattern you know with
the technology doesn't come before the
desire right okay right exactly the the
the technology comes with the the
pattern playing itself out like the
desire to to see to disconnect sexuality
from procreation right that that is an
ideological move right and that was
happened before the the technology that
that would then give people what they
want right well like I said it does
create a sterile I mean a sterile world